earlier this year I shared an update
video letting you know that
unfortunately my dad had passed away
from bowel cancer really quite suddenly
we found out about his terminal
diagnosis in late January and he passed
away at the start of April however about
2 weeks before we received my dad's
diagnosis we received some other news
which was
that I was going to be a
dad everyone I'd like you to
meet well oh there's her mother's jeans
all right this is pixel baby she was
born just a couple of days ago and I'm
very happy to say that both baby and Mom
are doing amazingly uh pixel wife was
absolutely extraordinary um I couldn't
be more proud of her I couldn't honestly
at this point I couldn't be more in love
with her either it was not an easy easy
Labor uh it took quite a long time until
all of a sudden baby just decided that
actually no she was she was ready and
she was going to come out so um it was
it was a very interesting couple of days
I want to take this opportunity to just
say that the midwives at the r in bath
were extraordinary um exactly as we
found with the nurses who took care of
my dad early this year nurses and
midwives are angels they're miracle
workers they deserve to be paid more
stop underfunding the NHS and please
stop voting conservative now obviously
our new arrival has completely upended
our lives in the best way possible and
so I'm going to be taking some time off
work I'm going to be off for all of
October with videos returning in
November however whilst I'm off I'm
delighted to say that you're going to be
seeing videos from two guest
contributors you're going to be seeing
videos from Michael from the excellent
YouTube channel distilled all about
climate change and you're going to be
seeing a video from Sam who some of you
may recognize as a PhD student at the
University of Cambridge he was in his
own episode at the PHD stories series
and you may also recognize him from this
monstrosity of a t-shirt from my recent
event instantly planning an event with a
birth possible at any moment
was quite stressful considering that I'm
going to be missing an entire month of
income now it's probably a good time to
mention that if you like my work and
you'd like to support me then there are
lots of ways you can if you'd like to
directly support me then you can sign up
to my Pat which will be linked in the
description you get behind the scenes
content Early Access to videos and you
can choose video topics though uh not
for little while you could also buy my
book firmament but there are also lots
of free ways to support me including
just sharing one of my videos on social
media or in a group chat that's a huge
help and you could also listen to my new
podcast that launched recently how to
make a science video in which myself and
fellow YouTuber Sophie Ward talked to
top science creators like Brian from
midd engineering and Simone yet and Tio
about how they make their videos it's
available Wherever You cast your pods
there'll be a link in the description to
say that this year has been a roller
coaster would be putting it mildly
compared to the start of the year I will
finish it impoverished in some ways but
in
others Rich beyond my wildest dreams my
dad did know about the baby before he
passed away in fact we went from our
early scan in one section of the
hospital to his ward in another section
of the hospital to show him the pictures
and
um I I'm really glad that he knew and
um and it must have been bit of sweet
for him but I know that he was happy to
know that things are
um life carries
on oh God I feel obliged in this video
to head off a bunch of incredulous
comments at the pass I'm sure there are
lots of people who will be typing
comments about the apparent hypocrisy of
me as a climate YouTuber having a baby
and there'll be people saying that I'm
I'm making the problem worse and I'm
doing the most destructive thing
imaginable perhaps there's a whole video
to be made about this issue but for now
all I'll say is that uh this is not a
decision that pixel wife and I have made
lightly and that the whole point of what
I do is trying to keep the Earth
habitable and wonderful for future
generations and that's not going to
happen if there are no future
Generations that's it from me for now I
can't tell you how much I'm looking
forward to spending time as a family
and becoming a dad I was supposed to
have somebody here to guide me along
that path and to share and a new chapter
together
but we play the hand we dealt my dad's
supposed to be here and he's not and I
can't change
that now what's important is that I live
up to his example I'm sorry you couldn't
meet the best dad in the world but you
can hopefully meet the second best dad
in the
world I'm going to embarrass you so much
thank you for watching and I'll see you
in another a little
while I was there he would say
afterwards until afterwards became a
Time quite devoid of laughter I was
there the day Horus slew the emperor it
was a delicious conceit and his comrades
would chuckle at the sheer treason of it
the story was a good
one to